elisa diekmann ist seit november
vergangenen jahres bürgermeisterin
wir treffen die 34 jährige sie ist die
erste frau im amt die jüngste und sie
ist die erste ohne cdu-parteibuch
diekmann ist parteilos
mehr als 66 prozent haben bei den
kommunalen wahlen für sie gestimmt damit
rechnen konnte sie nicht es gab
reichlich skepsis als diekmann
kandidierte was haben sie im wahlkampf
zu hören bekommen als junge frau ich
habe immer wieder gehört ist sie nicht
zu jungen sie könnte irgendwie auch die
enkelin sein
hat sie überhaupt führungserfahrung
warum hat sie überhaupt kinder bekommen
wenn sie jetzt so ein amt übernimmt
viele bedenken vieles sehr persönlich es
gab sprüche ich würde nur gewählt werden
weil ich hübsch bin auf den plakaten ich
habe mich gefragt
ich habe ein gesicht auf einem
wahlplakat gehabt ich habe noch nie
jemanden gesehen der ein wahlplakat
anders dargestellt hat aber wenn ich das
mache ist das eine selbstdarstellung
wenn das ein mann macht das ganz normal
diekmann lebt getrennt von ihrem mann
ein aupair mädchen unterstützt sie mit
ihren zwei kleinen kindern
auch diekmanns privatleben war im
wahlkampf thema
die cdu habe die trennung von ihrem mann
öffentlich gemacht also es wurde wurde
versucht ja auch zu zeigen dass ich
nicht fähig bin dieses amt auszuführen
und da wurde schon so indirekt gesagt ja
wenn sie ihre private beziehung schon
nicht auf die reihe kriegt wie wir sie
dann eine stadtverwaltung führen
diekmann reagierte mit offenheit und
einem facebook video
da ist schon einige spekulationen von
seiten der cdu gibt werde ich heute noch
mal kurz ein bisschen transparenter sein
in privater sache mein mann marcus und
ich haben uns vor über einem jahr
getrennt diekmann hatte sich vorher
überlegt ob sie allen ansprüchen gerecht
wird mit einer wohnung neben dem rathaus
so dass sie mittags zu ihren kindern
kann mit weniger sitzungen am späten
nachmittag aber die bürgermeisterin mit
kleinen kindern sorgt im wahlkampf für
debatten
für mich
spielt es eine rolle ob ich qualifiziert
bin dass ich die ergebnisse liefern
aber wie ich das organisiere mit meinen
privaten bedürfnissen
das war für mich einfach nicht präsent
dass das eine rolle spielt diekmann ist
im amt angekommen aber das amt erst mal
zu bekommen ist für frauen weiter schwer
ein blick auf den frauenanteil in der
politik zeigt frauen sind in allen
bereichen unterrepräsentiert es gibt
derzeit 14 ministerpräsidenten und
gerade mal zwei ministerpräsidentinnen
der frauenanteil in deutschen landtagen
liegt durchschnittlich bei etwa 30
prozent
nur neun prozent der bürgermeister sind
weiblich und auch in den deutschen
parteien gibt es mehr männliche als
weibliche mitglieder
[Musik]
isabel rathgeb aus baden württemberg
will ins parlament die 40 jährige
christdemokratin hat drei kinder und
kandidiert für den baden
württembergischen landtag
es ist anfang märz ratgeb ist im
wahlkampf unterwegs
der frauenanteil in der politik ist im
ländle im vergleich zu anderen
bundesländern besonders niedrig haben
sie das gefühl dass sie darlegen
verkrustete strukturen ankämpfen müssen
es gibt gremien das sind leider gar
keine frauen vertreten
da mussten wir erstmal daran gewöhnen
dass er halt auch eine andere art von
politik stil reinkommt die selbständige
betriebswirtin kam 2009 10 über die
frauen union in die politik die
kreisrätin will jetzt in den landtag das
geht in baden württemberg nur über ein
direktmandat doch dafür werden frauen
seltener nominiert isabel rath geht
musste sich gegen einen mann in einer
kampfkandidatur durchsetzen
was brauchen wir noch mehr frauen hier
in der politik also fand ich ganz
spannend weil in baden württemberg hat
26 prozent im landtag also noch mehr
ja das wünsche ich mir dass wir dann
auch mehr haben aber da habe ich dann
schon eine gewisse angst wahrgenommen
ich weiß aber nicht vorher die angst
schürt die angst entstammt einem eher
traditionellen frauenbild das hier
gerade unter älteren männern noch weit
verbreitet scheint
warum
männer sind realisten frauenträume
sachen zu hause die haben halt angeles
angekommen
sie haben andere waffen kommen sie mit
politik vielleicht ewige zeit der
eigentlich sind mehr männer in der
politik fordert jemanden haben die
gewisse kultur die wettbewerbs kultur
traditioneller art der männer bereiche
zu verteidigen und dazu gehört dann eben
auch die frau als eindringling isabel
ratgeb ärgert sich darüber
sie erlebt immer wieder dass viele
frauen sich dadurch verunsichern lassen
und frauen erleben auch ganz praktische
hindernisse die sitzungen beginnen halt
meistens 19 19 30 das ist natürlich ein
arbeitsamt deshalb ein oft korreliert
ist mit der vesper zeit und natürlich
dass es zuerst die kinder ins bett gehen
weil man dann halt einfach jemand
braucht wenn die kinder fallen noch
kleiner sind da natürlich auch für die
familie da ist direktkandidatin isabel
ratgeb ist in einem für die cdu nicht
sehr aussichtsreichen wahlkreis
angetreten und sie hat verloren
wir schauen in ein ministerium in dem
der frauenanteil traditionell gering ist
michelle müntefering ist
staatsministerin im auswärtigen amt
hier sind mächtige frauen selten in der
geschichte der bundesrepublik gab es
bislang mehr beamtete staatssekretäre
mit dem vornamen hans als frauen
müntefering nimmt uns mit an einen ort
wo das deutlich wird müntefering hat
ganz bewusst den posten ihrer
büroleitung mit einer frau besetzt das
sei selten
und müntefering ist schirmherren des
frauenvereins im auswärtigen amt sie
setzt auf netzwerke
es darf nicht sein dass männer schon
alles zu sagen unter sich besprochen
haben bevor dann die frauen auch noch
informiert werden das ist offen so in
der politik und deswegen brauchen wir
genau auf diese vernetzung auch symbole
seien wichtig im auswärtigen amt gibt es
dutzende von besprechungsräumen michelle
müntefering zeigt uns den hildegard hamm
brücher sal
wir haben erst in dieser
legislaturperiode überhaupt die ersten
räume nach frauen benannt
das hier ist der zweite ellinor von
puttkamer ist der erste danach nach
einer frau genannt wurden ist einer
großen diplomaten sind also auch die
symbole da kommt auch darauf an dass man
diese sichtbarkeit eben auch erhöht am
sichtbarsten wäre wohl eine
außenministerin
bis heute gab es noch keine in
deutschland frauen ganz oben an der
spitze
angela merkel ist eine der wenigen
ausnahmen merkel selbst hat ihre rolle
als erste frau im kanzleramt ganz selten
öffentlich thematisiert in ihrer
amtszeit ist beim frauenanteil im
bundestag wenig passiert und sie selbst
ist merkel selbst ein vorbild
niemand lacht ein junges mädchen heute
mehr aus wenn es sagt dass es später
immer ministerin oder sogar
bundeskanzlerin werden will
es soll sogar schon fragen geben ob es
auch ein mann werden darf
jetzt will wieder eine frau ins
kanzleramt als grüne spitzenkandidatin
hat sich annalena baerbock gegen robert
habeck durchgesetzt aber natürlich hat
auch die frage der emanzipation eine
zentrale rolle bei dieser entscheidung
gespielt
frau jung und mutter das ist
ungewöhnlich schafft sie da überhaupt
den spitzenposten diese frage muss
berbalk beantworten sie scheint ganz
normal
aber müssen männer solche fragen auch
beantworten
wir treffen tobias hans
ministerpräsident des saarlandes
der 43 jährige kam vor drei jahren ins
amt und wurde einige monate später vater
von zwillingen
anfang des jahres kam sein drittes kind
zur welt
herr hans wie oft werden sie gefragt wie
sie familie und beruf unter einen hut
bringen
eigentlich erstaunlich oft etwa bei der
geburt meiner zwillinge aber natürlich
werde ich das in einem anderen kontext
gefragt als frauen bei frauen schwingt
immer so mit wie kannst du das schaffen
trotz des jobs eine gute mutter zu sein
während das bei mir eigentlich gefühlt
nicht so mit schwingt und das ist
eigentlich nicht okay wie beurteilen sie
denn in diesem zusammenhang die
diskussion um die kanzlerkandidatur von
annalena baerbock
also ich finde es grundsätzlich gut dass
frauen das auch jüngere frauen dass
mütter sich um das politisch wichtigste
staatsamt bewerben
und selbstverständlich kann eine frau
politische spitzen position haben wenn
sie mutter ist und im übrigen umgekehrt
wenn eine frau keine mutter ist dann
werden wir auch diese fragen gestellt
dann heißt es sehr viel eher mal wie
kann diese frau bundeskanzlerin sein wo
sie selbst keine mutter ist das würde
man bei einem mann da gibt es ja auch
einige die keine kinder haben
würde man das weniger stellen und das
ist absolut nicht in ordnung
frauen in der politik würden öfter
hinterfragt als männer sagt hans er will
frauen gezielt fördern aber eine
frauenquote in der cdu das bleibe doch
schwierig
die einführung einer quote bei der cdu
vertagt annegret kramp karrenbauer hat
eine frauenquote als cdu-parteichefin
jedenfalls nicht hinbekommen
dabei wird sie seit jahren dafür selbst
ein abgestuftes modell konnte sie nicht
durchsetzen
warum hat es am ende nicht geklappt
es waren sehr grundsätzliche
auseinandersetzung mit dem thema quote
braucht man das überhaupt es gab ja auch
viele auch viele jüngere die gesagt
haben wir wir brauchen überhaupt gar
keine quotenregelung dann gibt es
natürlich auch immer die debatte wenn
wir das so einführen was heißt das
eigentlich für die mitglieder etwa
unserer vereinigung werden die dann
benachteiligt
seit einem vierteljahrhundert gibt es
lediglich das weniger verbindliche
quorum
auf die kuriert aber kramp karrenbauer
selbst ebnete es den weg
[Musik]
sie sagen selbst dass sie von der quote
profitiert haben inwiefern eine erste
kandidatur auf einer liste für den für
den bundestag war genauso ein frauen
platz bei dem dann auf einmal im rahmen
der versammlung von jetzt auf gleich
jemand gesucht wurde und es musste aber
eine frau sein und das hat für mich die
chance eröffnet wenn man sich ein system
volkspartei wie das der cdu anschaut das
funktioniert eigentlich alles irgendwie
immer nach quoten es wird geschaut wir
sind die konfessionszugehörigkeit
arbeitnehmer unternehmer aus welchem
ortsteil kommt jemanden das ist auch nie
ein problem wird auch nie diskutiert
außer wenn es um frauen geht die wenigen
frauen an der spitze verzerren das bild
im bundestag ist der frauenanteil
rückläufig der höchstwert lag bei 36,5
prozent in der vergangenen
legislaturperiode
jetzt beträgt der 31,4 prozent
die verteilung in den fraktionen ist
unterschiedlich bei den grünen und der
partei die linke sind frauen in der
mehrheit die spd fraktion kommt auf 42
prozent
diese parteien haben quotenregelungen
bei der fdp der union und der afd
der frauenanteil deutlich geringer
in berlin sind wir mit helga lukat
verabredet die politikwissenschaftlerin
arbeitet gerade an einer studie zu
frauen in der politik werden zum
beispiel herausgefunden dass ganz andere
erwartungen an frauen in der politik
gestellt werden als männer was ihre
leistung betrifft da wird auf dem
doppelten maß gemessen sind eher auf dem
prüfstand als männer welche rolle
spielen auch bedrohungen und
beschimpfungen leider eine viel zu große
und sie haben er auch zugenommen durch
die sozialen netzwerke durch den ton der
dort herrscht da geht es oft auch
wirklich an ihre identität als frau es
wird ihre sexualität in frage gestellt
und und und also wüste beschimpfungen
auch claudia roth bekommt den hass zu
spüren
sie ist seit 2013 vizepräsidentin des
deutschen bundestages
wie erleben sie denn das klima frauen
gegenüber im parlament das hat sich
absolut verändert es ist aggressiver
geworden es ist an machender gewarnt die
erfahrung die frauen im parlament machen
ist das allein ist der weg zum redepult
schon begleitet wird wie man wird von
oben bis unten betrachtet das sind nicht
pfeifen ist verwundert ein und dann
kommen halt einfach ziemlich unflätige
bemerkungen man kann das wort sogar
benutzen es ist sehr stark geprägt von
sexismus
ein neues klima im parlament und eine
neue perspektive
ehrlich gesagt ich habe bei manchen
kollegen das gefühl dass nachdem klar
war dass angela merkel nicht mehr
antreten wird sich jetzt die männer
wieder ja dass so ein aufatmen kommt so
jetzt kommen wir wieder zurück in die
alten richtigen verhältnisse rot ist für
ministern der ersten stunde
jetzt sieht sie den einfluss von frauen
im parlament schwinden es brauche die
quote die frauen sind in diesem
machtkampf natürlich angewiesen dass es
regeln gibt die ihnen überhaupt
ermöglichen zu zeigen was sie können das
ist die frauenquote die frauenquote ist
nicht mehr als ein schlüssel als mittel
zum zweck ein schlüssel der die tür
aufmacht und dann muss die frau
reingehen und muss zeigen dass es sehr
wohl kann
ein argument das nicht von allen frauen
geteilt wird
corinna herold ist abgeordnete der afd
in thüringen
heute ist sie mit ihrem mobilen
bürgerbüro im erfurter norden unterwegs
oder wenn ja in ihrer fraktion im
landtag gibt es 15 männer und drei
frauen eine quote lehnt herold ab warum
sind sie gegen eine quote
wer eine quote braucht und das meine ich
jetzt nicht nur frauen bezogen sondern
egal wo gerade jetzt zum arbeiten
entweder ungeeignet aus dummheit
faulheit wie auch immer oder für
karrierewege mit charme und witz und
weiblichen vorzüge neben offensichtlich
zu unansehnlich ist das sehr ernst das
ist die volkstümliche variante seines
standpunktes jahr vielleicht braucht es
aber erstmal eine quote um so ein pendel
rand zu bekommen und damit fangen wir
gar nicht erst an
entweder wir sind gleich und frei oder
nicht und wir haben im grundgesetz da
steht es drinnen alle menschen sind vor
dem gesetz gleich und da brauche ich
keine quote das ruiniert nur langfristig
den ruf derer die diese quote in
anspruch nehmen wir antworten für
kleingärtner für angler für einbeinige
für gehörlose ich möchte nicht als
quotenfrau irgendwo apostrophiert werden
aber wie dann den frauenanteil in der
politik erhöhen
frauen müssten selbst initiativ werden
sagt die 59 jährige kam und frauen und
männer aus ihrer sicht die selben
chancen ja ja die müssen die frauen
einfach nur ergreifen ich habe auf ihren
veranstaltungen mit frauen gesprochen
und versucht sie zur mitarbeit zu
bewegen aber wir standen oft ganz andere
interessen im vordergrund
familie arbeitsplatz freizeit gestaltung
yogakurs und töpfern
das trifft mich so auf eine resonanz
ihre chance ergriffen hat linda
teuteberg
sie war generalsekretären der fdp ein
gutes jahr lang bis sie 2020 von
parteichef lindner aus dem amt gedrängt
wurde auf dem parteitag verabschiedete
er sie mit einem herrn witz dass wir in
den vergangenen 15 monaten ungefähr 300
mal den tag zusammen begonnen haben
ich spreche über unser tägliches
morgendliches telefonat zur politischen
lage nicht was er denkt
[Musik]
freud heute wie stehen sie denn zu ihrer
verabschiedung durch christian lindner
auf dem parteitag 2020 christian lindner
hat sich entschuldigt und damit ist auch
der konkrete vorfall für mich
abgeschlossen
ich finde es allerdings tatsächlich sehr
wichtig insgesamt dafür zu
sensibilisieren für die frage was sind
noch rollenbilder und typische dinge die
frauen erleben und diese debatte die
brauchen wir heute bergs fdp heftet das
image einer männerpartei an der anteil
der frauen in der führungsspitze ist
gerade weiter geschrumpft was macht
frauen den aufstieg so schwer zu sagen
ich bewerbe mich das wird frauen oft als
überehrgeizig ausgelegt und nicht
anerkannt als normales verhalten eines
erwachsenen menschen
was auch für frauen in ordnung ist
eisprinzessin bis so ein titel den
kritiker benutzen wenn man
durchsetzungsfähig ist dinge die bei
männern positiv bewertet werden als
verhaltensweisen werden frauen schnell
zum vorwurf gemacht
trotz ihrer persönlichen erfahrungen
linda teuteberg ist gegen jede
frauenquote freiwillige
zielvereinbarungen sollen helfen ganz
die liberale linie aber hilft das
tatsächlich frauen bleiben in der
minderheit
es fehlt an vereinbarkeit an vorbildern
viele strukturen sind männlich geprägt
solange sich das nicht ändert haben
frauen weniger chancen quoten auch
übergangsweise können das ändern und
männer die auf macht verzichten
zugunsten von frauen in der politik